I
okay when we go ahead and get started
welcome everyone I guess we can consider
this to be the first talk of the new
school year even though school doesn't
officially start until next week this is
a fun day for me although it's one of
those days that are both exciting and
great about the program and then starts
to make you feel realize how old you are
[Music]
as I think everyone knows dr. adam
wright who's here today doing a couple
things one of which is receiving an
award from the School of Medicine Alumni
Association for early career achievement
and of course we're taking advantage of
that by having him visit with us and
Adams PhD again I think all of you know
he was the first in the first cohort of
PhD students in our program and then was
the first to graduate and he's gone on
to do all kinds of great things in
informatics at Harvard Medical School we
always remind people that we've trained
a number of successful Harvard
informatics faculty of which Adam is one
and so he's here visiting today he'll
he's obviously giving this talk he'll be
meeting with the fellows and there's a
reception in the gallery out here at
three o'clock that everyone is invited
to you should have signed up but if you
didn't that's okay you can still come
and the Alumni Association is actually
going to present Adam with an award so
just a little bit about history Adam
actually did grow up in the Portland
area and like us we go and then he went
off to college at Stanford and right
when we were launching our program he
launching our PhD program of course we
already had our masters and Erin
training grant and so forth Adam applied
he was certainly a highly desirable
candidate we had a feeling he was going
to do pretty well on the field we were
delighted when he chose to come study
here so he started in our program in
2004 and managed sexy graduate in three
years 2007 and then went off to Brigham
and Women's harvard medical school and
working he's actually worked with a lot
of people dean siddig david bates others
and now has worked up in the ranks to
become associate professor and has his
own independent research program a
couple our ones and is very well known
nationally for his work in decision
support and other areas of clinical
informatics and he also won the AMIA new
investigator award several years back I
can't remember exactly which year David
door also won that award along the way
and were delighted that he's going to be
able to spend some time give us a talk
on some of the more technical and
academic aspects of his work and let us
know what what he's up to well I just
wanted that we're actually having a
number of luminaries here this fall in
addition to Adam I just want to remind
everyone that on October 28 is the 25th
anniversary of the big building
celebration one of our actually we have
a lot of speakers coming and the kind of
keynote address that's going to finish
the event is dr. Patricia Brennan who is
the new director of the National Library
medicine and we're one of the first NLM
training programs to get her I'm sure
they're all vying to do so but we were
very well organized and invited her and
the day she got announced as
Allen director anyways so i won't
further cut into Adams time I will let
him talk and those who are listening in
cyberspace can twit tweak to hashmi
hashtag demise comp if you want to ask a
question so I'm just delighted to be
here I appreciate the very kind
introduction several parts of it were
true and so um it feels like a real
homecoming right i mean i think about
all the classes that I took here in the
pic gallery I still see a lot of my
distinguished faculty and classmates and
friends here i'm a proud graduate of
ohsu I try to tell people about ohsu
whenever I km and David's right a lot of
the people i work with that at the
burger man of Harvard including my boss
was the chief of medicine as a hsu
alumnus he did his residency here so
there's a lot of connections between
this department and the department that
I'm in now so I'm just so happy to to be
back here among friends and talking
about some of the research that I'm
doing and she wanted to start my talk
just remembering Mark Richardson for for
a second and I picked this picture
because I want to find a picture of him
sort of doctoring that's actually how I
first met him when I was in graduate
school I was his patient I'd have my
tonsils out which is not the world's
biggest surgery would they always say
like a the only minor surgery is what
happened to someone else so I was a
little bit nervous about it and he was a
tremendous doctor he was really
compassionate person and I really
appreciated the care of it he provided
me and I got to know him better once he
became Dean when I was a student here
and actually when I was graduating I was
one of the student speakers and I was
quite nervous and so so he and I were
sort of sharing the stage together he
calmed me down which I really appreciate
it and I always have remembered the
remarks that he gave it our commencement
he was talking about sort of the immense
privilege we have whether it's
physicians or scientists or imitations
to be involved in our patients lives and
to sort of you know be there you know an
important time for them and also they
sort of you know responsibility that
that creates a sort of do our best every
day because people are counting on us
and so there's definitely been some
tough days I've had at work where I've
tried to remember piano
since words and so just wanted to
remember him for a second but before I
started it was certainly a visionary
leader for our medical school you were
lucky to have them and I think he's
going to be a hard act to follow but she
wanted to to say something about them
before it started so no easy transition
so I have no conflicts of interest or
financial relationships to disclose I
work at an academic hospital I don't
have any special stock or ownership in
any companies or get any special money
or anything like that but the first half
of my talk is going to be work that we
described in this Jamie at paper so this
is analysis of clinical decision support
malfunctions we talked about sort of
four case studies for my hospital so the
first half a little bit more
retrospective if you want to learn more
about it check out this paper the second
half is new stuff that we haven't
published yet that I think sort of
extends this work I just want to point
out that if you're interested in going
deeper I would recommend this this paper
to you so you know looking at the
audience I don't think I have to sort of
sell you on the benefits of clinical
decision support we know the decision
support is good when it's working
properly it can improve the quality of
care and you know make things more
efficient help us avoid adverse drug
events or other kinds of errors or
safety issues in the hospital and one
thing that was surprising to us and
actually we largely learn this in some
work that i did with that jonah and
acidic and the poet team here is that
decision support often or we thought
maybe malfunctions and so you know kind
of the classic example of this is that
we would be on a site visit and we'd ask
somebody to show us some example of
their decision support they would try to
do that and it wouldn't work right and
we would be surprised and they would be
surprised and we would try to easily get
to the bottom of it so the genesis of
this project actually has to do with the
talk i was giving not unlike this one so
this is this is a nostalgic screenshot
for me this is the longitudinal medical
record which is the electronic medical
record that we used to have at the
Brigham and Women's Hospital you guys
may not know about a year ago we switch
to epic so so we followed an ear in your
footsteps but for a long time this was
our outpatient EMR
and like a lot of Myanmar's it sort of
divided into sections right there's a
problem list there's a medication list
there's an allergy list whose place for
lab results and notes and we have always
been rather proud of this top section
here we call reminders and so this is
one kind of rule based decision support
that we have you can see there are
reminders here for things like bone
densitometry and documenting patient's
height and weight and given their
medications checking various lab results
and we have a number of papers that have
shown over in the past that reminders
like those and other kinds of decision
support in that system have improved
quality and reduced safety events and
reduced errors and so we have a terrific
knowledge management team and a group of
researchers that it sort of builds on
this decision support but what we hadn't
really appreciated very much is that
there were sometimes problems with the
decision support so I was giving a talk
not unlike this one I was trying to give
a demo I was feel nervous given why I'm
gonna give a live demo in the second
half of my talk that's owners gonna give
a live demo because you never know
what's going to happen and so I was
turning of a live demo of this and get
this particular decision support which
is a for patients taking amiodarone we
suggest checking their thyroid function
their liver function every year and so
if they've been on the mint for at least
a year we have a very simple rule that
just says you know check the TSH and
check the ALP if those things haven't
been checked and so we I was trying to
demo this I pulled up a test patient
that have been on am your room for at
least a year and didn't have a TSH
result and thought the alert would show
up and it didn't and I felt nervous and
I told up another test patient in fact a
few things no matter what I did I
couldn't couldn't get it to fire and so
I when I went back to my office i
emailed our knowledge our engineers the
guys what's going on they're like no and
so we did a little bit of Investigation
and eventually figured out this is sort
of the pseudocode of the rule so
basically if the patient is on drug 40
with a start date that's more than 365
days ago and they're TSH value isn't
there there's more than your old and
suggests the TSH but at some point
somebody in the pharmacy had changed the
ID number for amiodarone from 40 to 70
99 but the people who
we're in turn to the rule didn't know
that and so that was awkward and so this
is a graph that shows the the firing of
the rule the Milwaukee throat is a
little bit tricky so the dark blue dots
are weekend days and the light blue dots
are weekdays this is primarily this is
really it's an outpatient system and so
not surprisingly there is more use of it
on weekdays that then on weekends and
you can see it's maybe a little bit
subtle but you know in the beginning
it's sort of going up and then the green
bar sort of shows where the problems
started and what happened was on that
day we switched the code from 40 to 70
99 but we didn't switch it for everybody
right it was just for patients that were
newly starting on the trougs if you're
already on amiodarone you still had code
40 in your chart it was only if it knew
Lee started am I wrote on that you got
70 99 so they see what happens over time
is some patients get taken off the drug
new patients get put on the drug so
around this point in time rather than it
going up it starts to sort of slowly
fade out and then on this date I gave a
demo and felt embarrassed and then the
next day we fixed the problem and you
can see the sort of firing rate I jumped
back up to what was expected so if I've
been working the whole time it sort of
would have just gone you know straight
up like this but instead it went sort of
went up and then down and have like a
big jump right there so that was bad and
so you can see that for a couple years
we had this sort of malfunction
persisting so we fixed that and then I
got nervous I said you'd we have other
problems like this in our decision
support so we started looking at the
bodega de and we found some that we're
pretty clear so this is a LED screening
alert for two-year-olds basically if
you're two years old you don't have a
recent LED test then we suggest checking
the patient's LED level we have a lot of
old houses in Boston and reasonable
incidents of lead poisoning and you can
see it's sort of going along and firing
then it sort of you know kind of Peters
out and then it stops for like two years
and then suddenly restarts and it was
really confusing what happened we looked
we have this sort of manually maintained
changelog where we keep track of edits
made the rules there was no evidence
that this rule had ever been changed the
last known changed this rule
was in 2006 and there are similar rules
for one year olds three year olds and
four year olds they all ran just fine so
we didn't think I'd anything to do with
like a change in the way led tests were
reported or how age was reported and so
we know what to do so we managed to pull
a sort of programmer out of retirement
and we discovered that there was this
audit log it was supposed to tell us who
the rules that ever been changed and we
realized that there was actually a bug
in the audit log so you couldn't
actually reconstruct what happened in
the rules but no one had ever looked in
the auto logs and no one knew but she
eventually helped us think what if we
got the backup tapes and like restored
the LMR to you know this day in this day
and look to see what happens we got
these dusty tapes out of our Iron
Mountain storage and restored the LMR
and eventually figured out that we think
accidentally a knowledge engineer the
rule logic is if you're too and no LED
test then LED test accidentally added a
and you are a current smoker clause to
the rule and so the number of two year
old smoker they actually fired once but
the negative two year old smokers is a
smaller sample and so so that was a
weird thing and we think you know we
talked about wrong patient errors right
we think this was just your arm cool air
we think the discount engineer was
trying to edit one rule and actually
picked another rule I don't have a good
picture of it but the screen where you
edit the rules is not terribly intuitive
and it's not always obvious exactly
which what's kind of yes but it's not
super obvious which rule you're editing
and so we think that there was just a
mistake that was made and then somehow
somebody found that mistake a few years
later and just sort of quietly fixed it
but a question I'm going to ask is like
is it reasonable that this would just be
broken for like two years and the answer
is probably no and so we thought it
would be good if there was more
proactive way of finding these functions
and so I was a math major in college was
anyone else a math major in college that
was the correct behavior good answer so
the best thing to major in and those of
you who were math majors or took us
across may be familiar with the Poisson
distribution which is sort of like that
you know expected number of events that
happened in sort of a period of time and
you know has one parameter lambda which
is basically like the number of event so
if you imagine like you own a tire store
and you expected five people to come in
your tires during an hour then it might
be police aw I'm distributed with
parameter lambda equals five and then
you would sort of say to yourself like
okay if one person came into my tire
store how weird would that be you know
it would be a little weird right because
usually five but you know it turns out
maybe there's like a five or six percent
chance that you get you know one person
it might be really weird if 30 people
came into your tire store you might say
wow that's seen or not explained by the
expected sort of probability
distribution and so there's this
question which is somehow like you know
if I have a process that I assume a sort
of place on distributed does the lambda
parameter change try it and so somehow
you might assume that you know for if
you just focused on weekdays that the
sort of lambda expected number of
firings of this rule would be around 250
and then would it be unusual than to c0
firings or a run of zero fighters answer
is yes that would be very unlikely
statistically and so poised on change
point detection is about kind of
figuring out that okay it appears most
likely that there was some change to the
lambda parameter so we ran this
algorithm and the blue bar shows what it
detected is the sort of like unusual run
of behavior so not surprisingly the big
sort of chunk in the middle here where
the rule wasn't firing was detected to
be abnormal or unexpected behavior so so
we thought we could sort of turn this on
for all of our rules and use it as an
alerting system basically to find these
potential functions it doesn't work
perfectly though so this is the green
bar shows is back to the amiodarone
thing we talked about before the green
bar shows when the actual malfunction
happen but the blue mark shows when our
basic place on a change point detector
found the malfunction eek so you can see
there's quite a substantial detection
delay almost a year from when my
function happen doing this very basic
statistical detector found it so we'll
talk more later in the talk about sort
of more advanced to disability because
we not fella that find these things with
a much shorter detection delay but it's
at least possible so we then ran these
detectors on the rest of our rules and
found some unusual behavior so this is a
rule that reminds there's a joke in this
slide but i'm not sure what it is so
that reminds you to do chlamydia
screening and you know on average we
recommend you know a 100 to 150
chlamydia screening today but for some
reason there were two days right here
where we wound up recommending you know
thousands of limited screens and so like
i said some joke so it turns out that
there that was the day that we upgraded
the LMR to a new version and we had
accidentally introduced a bug this is
the chart belongs to a make a nine month
old baby boy so you can see he's overdue
for like six pap smears and some
mammograms he has heart failure he needs
six or eight cholesterol assessments
that he has renal dysfunction he needs a
pap smear there's all kinds of weird
stuff going on here basically cuz of the
coding update that was intended to be
sort of benign every alert was just kind
of firing for every patient over and
over again and the big difference here
you can see this one only lasted for two
days is that when you start spamming
people with like crazy alerts they tend
to call you on the phone and say like
guys something weird is happening but
when you start when you forget to show
an alert you know people can not to call
so what we've largely seen is that the
sort of spikes are detected quickly
whereas the sort of drops often persist
for years and so it's probably important
to have statistical detection for both
of them but the sort of detection for
the drops might be more important
because you're less likely to sort of
notice notice that so it's a similar
reminder for patients on it with that
coronary artery disease we try to remind
them to take aspirin and you can see it
had the same spike that every rule more
or less had on that date and then there
was another few week long period of
malfunction and what happened there was
this sigh uses an external drug
classification service so basically the
logic of the rules if the patient has
coronary artery disease and they're not
on and I played a litter of like aspirin
or plavix or pass through gravel or
something like that then suggest it and
the drug classifier
it basically said that there were no
drugs at the anti plate of the class so
you would say you know my patient was
taking aspirin are they on antiplatelet
drugs would say no there are no
antiplatelet drugs in the world and so
this rule would fire for patients that
were on aspirin and people again
reported that one quickly but because it
depended on this external system it was
pretty hard for our knowledge engineers
to sort of chase down the problem they
would she figured it out and fix the
external system but that was a bummer
too because somehow you sort of lose a
little bit credibility at retiming have
these vcds malfunctions so after i did
this i thought i should write a paper
about it but i felt really nervous and
embarrassed because i was like is the
brigham the only place that's ever had
this kind of problem or other people had
these these problems so we did a survey
through am this and this is the sort of
a professional organization for CM iOS
and we just posted there was not a
really representative sample we just
emailed it out to the end us mailing
list and 29 people took the survey and
really asked something had ever had
problems like this and the first thing
we asked them before we get to the punch
line is you have CES and most of them
did they had you know ddis and algae
alerts at less in the way of reminders
to patients but it seemed like a pretty
typical population and depending on your
perspective either it's either good or
bad but a lot of people had these
problems so two respondents had never
said that said they had never had any
CVS malfunction at their hospital but
most of the respondents said that they
had had these malfunctions and we're
half the respondent said that they had
at my phone like this more than once a
year and the biggest group of
respondents said they had them four or
more times a year so I guess like I said
like in the way you don't want other
people have the problem because like
it's a problem also made it feel
slightly less alone at the brigham so we
asked people what contributed I was very
similar to what we had seen in our data
set so upgrades to HR software changes
to underline codes like the amiodarone
drug code we're major contributors
people report an inadvertent disabling
or enabling of a rule upgrade of another
system besides the EHR that Brooks EDS
or some other kind of database
corruption or system malfunction that
led to
so similar patterns we ask people if
they were confident that they had good
ways to detect these malfunctions and no
one was totally confident a few people
were very confident but most people were
you know somewhat confident not very
confident not at all confident so it
seemed like we were on to something that
there was some issue here where people
are having these EDS malfunctions and
didn't know that they could definitely
prevent them we asked people how they
were finding them and by far the most
prevalent mode of identification was
report from users so I user we called
help desk or email the sea mio and say I
think you see DX is broken and as we
know from our experience they're much
more likely to do that for CD s that is
firing too much than for CD s that is
not firing at all I mean regardless it's
not a good system to like depend on your
users to find the bugs in your software
and tell you about them but it's
especially frocked out you have these
drops which are pretty common other
people said I noticed in my own use of
the system so these are see my OS once
then we're practicing clinicians and
some of them said like winos I've never
gotten this alert that i built and seems
like this patient would fit the criteria
much less common were ongoing system
testing so you know go into the HR and
make sure the CVS is still turned on or
reviewing reports of CD s performance at
which we now think is probably actually
a best best practice despite its
relative in frequency at least to me at
the am dis sample so against the
conclusion was we weren't alone the
problems we were seeing were similar to
other problems and so we said you know
let's get a grant because we're
researchers and that's what we like to
do so we applied for funding from the
National Library of Medicine and we're
very lucky to get day grant from NLM to
sort of investigate this this problem
more fully so our goal was to develop
and evaluate an innovative approach to
proactively identify CBS failures
drawing from the field of anomaly
detection and so any of you have a
credit card you ever gotten a phone call
from your credit card company you know
if you're beyond and somebody calls and
says like Jionni do just by six Persian
rugs in Morocco and gone says yes but I
would probably say no and so you know
that's sort of a statistical rule-based
check that they're doing and basically
saying Lee compared to be honest normal
purchasing behavior that's unusual and
so maybe she didn't actually make make
those
kisses and I want to do the same thing
basically sort of look at the current
behavior of these alerts compare it to
their past behavior and then identify
red flags for the fact that they might
might be broken and so the police on
changed one thing that I showed is a
simple instance of that we've now built
much more complex instances of it so the
first aim because i learned from joan
was a qualitative aim and i was really
just about sort of wrapping our mind or
on the problem and going out and talking
to people investigating these kinds of
events and learning how how these
malfunctions occurred I'm trying to
develop some best practices for
permitting c.d.s failures and then the
next two aims which we'll get to in a
little bit are about sort of building
these anomaly detection systems and
disseminating the results and so we've
now done site visits to a bunch of
hospitals and analyze data and a we
should update this because it's now not
just Brigham Women's Hospital Ohio State
it's also holy spirit hospital memorial
hermann in texas and then we're about to
go to the news leave illinois in chicago
so I'm a little behind on that that oh
this slide is more updated but but
anyways so after we did that we had
eventually collected 44 examples or
cases of CD s malfunctions that we
wanted to analyze we collected other
kinds of data to write data on their
sort of governance data on their
detection strategies but we also sort of
pulled together these forty four
examples of CD s malfunctions and put
them into a database and Joan databank
spent a long time doing a sort of
virtual card sort last week trying to
sort of get this data in order so I
would have something to tell you guys
when I came to give this talk but for
the 44 cases from nine organizations
that we reviewed we were able to
identify the root cause in 36 of the
cases and in two of the cases we deemed
that they weren't CDs malfunctions at
all so one of them was sort of seediest
it was like working fine but people just
didn't like it and then one of them was
a malfunction in the reporting around CD
s rather than the malfunction at CES
itself and then 6 we had insufficient
information to determine the root cause
and so we conducted this card sort
exercise that identify common patterns
and build a taxonomy and so
the three dimensions of our taxonomy
sort of the method of discovery the
effect on rule firing and then the cause
of the malfunction so so the method of
discovery that was most prevalent was
sort of review this is a little
different than we saw in the and estate
but was sort of reviewing rule firing
data tied with reviewing user reports on
the am to sample reviewing user reports
was less common it was more commonly
reviewing firing data but basically you
know I think that reviewing hiring data
is a little bit of a proactive strategy
sort of looking at your fire data and
seeing whether your results that your
rules are not functioning being user
reports feels like how much more
reactive strategies waiting for user to
call help desk and complain we also have
developed a new process that we're just
trying to get to work of looking at
override reason comments so in our
system if you don't like an alert you
can override it and you have the option
to sort of say something and what we
discovered was that people type all
kinds of interesting things in there but
there are three patterns that are
particularly informative so if people
use a word like stupid or idiot in the
comment if they use a swear word or if
they use two or more exclamation points
in their comment and so we actually
found four different HR malfunction CVS
malfunctions that were discovered by
looking at these comments and you know
an example would be a rule that suggests
checking the the cyclosporin level for
patients taking cyclosporine and it was
fire informations were taking
cyclosporine eyedrops which are not like
systemically available and you don't
need to check the level if you're using
eye drops and people would write its eye
drops you stupid computer ! ! ! or a
rule that looked for insulin the
reminded people if patients were in the
ED for more than four hours and they
were on insulin at home to give insulin
in the hospital and what happened though
is that the doctor would order you know
insulin you know however many units you
know you know now once basically and
then that order would expire once the
drug admit administered and the computer
would then look for an active insulin
order and say there is no active insulin
order give insulin and people would
write I just gave insulin ! explanation
swear word and that would be assigned
for us so looking at override reasons
testing in either the test environment
production environment that found if you
look at things I guess you know which
example this is but demonstrating the
system in the talk was the cause of
finding one of the malfunctions and then
we'll talk a little bit in a second
about what we're called upstream anomaly
detection but that was another way that
we found at one case and I think we're
eventually going to find more more cases
using that that method so let's talk
about causes the most common cause of
cts malfunctions was actually not some
sort of external lightning strike like
in the four examples that I gave you but
just sort of a logic error so so most
commonly people sort of conceptualize
things wrong you know they didn't think
of cyclosporine I drop so they got
confused about the difference between an
order and administration so seven of the
cases were conceptualization issues four
of them were implementation issues so
somehow the rule was respect out
correctly but the person who built it in
the CD s editor made a mistake like a
typo basically in the implementation and
then a couple were interesting basically
like that rule did one thing and the
text said something else so the rule
might look for patients who were you
know the rule out information so were
over 40 and say give a mammogram but the
text would say patient is over 50 and
give a mammogram and for patient was 45
the ruled fire but then it would say
something that was like counterfactual
like patients over 50 when they were
really not over 50 and so that would be
an example of text Andrew logic don't
match so 13 these were these logic
errors the next most common pattern was
this new code thing where somebody in
the laboratory or the pharmacy or
somewhere else changed the codes and
that startled us and we weren't sort of
prepared for that one thing that we
hadn't anticipated that turned out to be
a really sort of brittle point was
environment migration issues so most
hospitals build their CD s and like one
environment they casted in another
environment they copy it to their
production environment in the end and we
saw a number of cases where people
either accidentally copied CD s from
test production that they didn't mean to
copy that like wasn't tested wasn't
ready or conversely somehow
I failed the copy CES from test into
production so when they tested I was on
but in the real system it wasn't or they
copy you know the main part of the CD s
but not something that it depended on
like a grouper and that caused a
malfunction so we think that these
environment migrations are a risky area
and we want to think more about sort of
what we would do about those there are a
few examples of actual software bugs
like where you know there was just a bug
in the HR and a programmer had to come
and fix the the bug a couple examples of
inadvertent disabling so somebody turned
a rule off thought when they didn't mean
to a couple examples of infrastructure
failure where you know a network link
went down or a server hard drive got
fried and that caused to see the
estimate function one interesting case
where you know epic in particular
encouraging sort of reuse content so you
know if you have like a list of all the
beta blockers you're supposed to sort of
you know use it in every rule that
involves beta blockers but then you know
somebody might pick a rule and say well
I'm really interested in cardio
selective beta blockers for this rules
they would edit the grouper and not
appreciate that that grouper was then
used in for other rules and that would
cause breakage and so we saw one example
with that and then one example was a
case where the format of a lab result
changed so so it's a funny story okay
Savannah minutes to tell attique I guess
I have enough minutes um so this was a
an alert that we had built that told
people when patients we thought we
should had sickle cell disease and it
wasn't on their problem list so the way
we did it was we looked at the results
of hemoglobin electrophoresis and so it
turns out that lake if you have sickle
cell disease you have a different kind
of hemoglobin that is sort of sticky and
weird and you can use electrophoresis to
viously figure out how much normal
hemoglobin and different weird kinds of
hemoglobin you have and so if you have
sickle cell disease you have nearly a
hundred percent type s hemoglobin if you
have sickle cell trait you have fifty
percent pay by seema globin if you have
neither of those you have zero percent
usually type s hemoglobin and so we had
a rule that basically to see if the type
s hemoglobin was greater than fifty
percent and if it was we suggested that
they add sickle cell disease to the
problem was
for some reason at you know so most
patients have zero percent right so
their rule doesn't fire but at some
point the lab switched from reporting
the number zero to the word I cider
absent or not detected but we'll just
say it was absent for a second and so
what happened in our EMR was it switched
from doing a numerical comparison
they're doing like a string comparison
right and so alphabetically absent comes
after 50 and the alert started firing
from all the patients who had ever had
this test it was negative so that was
awkward it was just another one of these
examples where when the lab made that
change there was no it wasn't obvious to
them was going to break the CDA probably
even know about the CD s but it broke in
kind of a hilarious and embarrassing
sort of way because now we're suggesting
like all these people have sickle cell
disease when they obviously don't have
sickle cell disease in the 12 or 14
hours of this was on we made like I
think 40 of these suggestions and like
eight of them were accepted to so i was
awkward i guess it says something about
how much for reading we actually asked
the doctors about half of them said they
like remember doing it my trusted and
have them were like oh I don't know I
just accept every alert I don't read
them and so that was scary too so those
are the causes and then sort of effects
you know what did it actually do to this
but you know lying chart that I was
showing you guys so the most common
thing was a rule fired for in eligible
patients 21 of the cases involved sort
of spikes were certified for the wrong
people most of them 12 of them the rule
was working correctly and then some
external thing change and caused the
spike at nine of the cases though it was
congenitally defective would you sort of
always broken in five of the cases the
rule stop firing not all the way that
most of the ways the Meo durrin was an
example of that five of the cases the
rule stop firing entire least the lead
example was an example of that in three
of the cases the rule had never fired
which is awkward and two of the cases
the rule kept firing correctly but
something went wrong with the action
where people couldn't take the action
reactions offered was incorrect given me
the logic of the rule so there's a lot
more
to do I think in terms of the sort of
taxonomy but we've been trying to
identify a few best practices sort of
around this and so as you might imagine
one of the best practices is just we
should be routinely reviewing firing
data and not just sort of counting on
user report and then some of these sort
of causes have kind of you know suggest
or lend themselves to their own best
practices right so the logic errors
might be solved by better testing or by
you know piloting the rule first in the
doing chart review the new code errors
might be solved by creating a procedure
where the lab or the pharmacy notifies
the rule owners before they make a
change to the codes or you know even
better somehow like something would
happen where if I tried to change the
amiodarone code I would get an alert
that said you know hey this you know
this decision support this order set
these things all depend on you know this
code you know please fix them or do you
want to automatically fix them or some
sort of dependency checker I think it
would be in order and it's not something
that we have right now so so we've been
thinking about that more about best
practices at the end if I have I have
time to do it so let's move on to the
math a min to sew a name to we said we
wanted to basically improve upon the
poise on change point detection I should
say just sort of level set we're in here
to of a four-year grant so so our
results are getting thinner as we go
through the aims because we're not done
yet I wanted to share some new stuff
with you guys rather than just the stuff
that we already published so we have
tried several different anomaly
detection methods now so expanded change
point detection beyond the sort of basic
poison to quit detection we have pretty
good luck with a technique called stl or
seasonal trend decomposition with Louis
and so the idea of stl is basically that
you have one of these you know time
series that you know you might first
realize it's seasonal so like you know
its most of our alerts are periodic with
a seven-day period so they're lower on
the weekends then on the weekdays some
of them like our flu vaccine alert
hasn't 365 day period to where it sort
of fires during flu season it doesn't
fire so you know stl first races
subtract out any seasonal or periodic
component
and then in general we're sort of taking
care of more patients over time so most
of everyone's have a general sort of
upward trajectory and so they call that
the trend components you try to subtract
out the trend component and then Louis
is just a method for sort of smoothing
you know things so there's some natural
variation so you sort of apply this low
as smoothing and then once you've done
those three things theoretically like
your signal should be less bumpy and if
it sort of jumps up or falls down that's
a better sign that it's like actually a
problem than if you just look at the raw
signal like we're doing in the change
point detection we're talking a bunch of
outliers course there's whole books and
conferences about sort of outlier scores
now our detection methods we're trying
to use some of those to figure them out
and so we have worked on you know sort
of detecting these things we discovery
is that different kinds of patterns seem
to have different lend themselves to
different detection methods and so one
of the things we talked about a sort of
baseline drift this is what I haven't
shown you guys yet but this is our
undocumented smoking status measure and
basically if the patient doesn't have
their smoking status documented ever we
suggest to their doctor that they do you
can see that this one pretty much just
falls over time and the reason is that
we're getting better at documenting
smoking status and the thing is it's
it's not do they have their smoking
status documented recently to the ethics
book that was documented ever at all and
so the idea is that once some document
once it almost always goes down except
that new patients also come come into
the system so this is a baseline drift
and this actually is an example of a
anomaly that is not enough function
right so this looks unusual to our
statistical anomaly detectors but
actually that's how the rule is supposed
to work and so we investigate it
included that was working correctly but
has a weird graph another solar example
of baseline drift is the sort of you
know amiodarone specific point with my
cursor sort of the amiodarone piece here
where it's sort of drifting up and then
suddenly the drift changes directions
are stripping down so that's weird and
then the third category of these sort of
things that we call a baseline shift so
somehow there's one baseline and then
suddenly is another baseline and
suddenly is another baseline and so the
change point detectors we talked about
are good examples of detectors
it effectively the sort of locate
baseline chefs and then a sort of
special case of baseline shift is what
we call like a sort of burst or spike
where for a short period of time there's
a lot of things and then suddenly it
goes back down and so you know a lot of
the this is crewmen site but a lot of
the literature on the nominally
detection comes from either financial
fraud or from computer networking so
hacker is trying to attack computer
networks as you can imagine that like if
you saw a pattern like this in your
server this might be a sign of a denial
of service attack where you know hackers
are trying to crash your server and in
this case the sign of a you know CES not
function where this external service
sort of went down so we're continuing to
work on anomaly detection algorithm sort
of I try to show that they're accurate
but now let me switch to the live demo
because I didn't learn my lesson last
time so I'll sit down for a second here
so this is the CD s alert dashboard that
we run at the brigham so every night we
dump out all the firing acceptance data
from our electronic health record and
then we sort of show these graphs you
can see we have you know a few examples
of you know alert changes right so
somehow this is an inpatient alert that
tells you when a patient needs a social
service consult and it was running at
this level and suddenly jumped up to
this level and we eventually figured out
that they had made a change to the logic
it was expected they sort of increased
the set of patients that were eligible
for for this alert similarly for this
allergy review thing they sort of made
it change the criteria and then also at
the same time they need to change the
criteria mgh so the second hospital in
my system went live on ethics there was
a big jump but just related to mgh sort
of going live other times they turned
alerts off and it turns out this alert
was just like really annoying so they
turned it off one thing that we've added
that turns out to be pretty cool is you
know these graphs are generally annoying
to look at because they have this sort
of periodic spiky component we created
this calendar visualization so you sort
of try to show them it's like a little
less grave gonna find one it's sort of
like the right amount of all right this
is a good example so somehow there's
some variation sort of during the
weekdays but on the weekends it tends to
basically not fire not fire
very much messier anesthesia is doing
less work on the weekend there's fewer
elective surgery cases like that so
somehow i feel like this calendar view
helps filter out some of the noise from
the weekly periodicity by letting you
sort of see what the weekdays look like
what the we kids look like it's always
putting to sea on Christmas you know the
25th it looks like a weekend or
something like that but we've tried to
add a few of these visualizations we've
also created some links it won't work as
on one side of the partners network to
our editing systems so you can actually
go from here to the system where we sort
of build the rules and track the history
of the rules and so you can sort of see
what changes have been made to the rules
we're trying right now to add some
additional support where will show when
additive made to the rules you know by
looking we basically sort of dumped out
the all the rules every day and then we
look to see if it's changed if a rule
has changed since yesterday then we can
superimpose a line it says on this date
they need to change this grouper to this
rule the it's been challenging
politically in resource wise to get that
file created but it looks like they
finally agreed to create it have a way
to create it so that's a new thing that
we're doing so um I have 15 minutes left
so let me show you a few other things
that I think are kind of cool and I want
to save a few minutes for questions at
the end so I realized I got tired of
checking the dashboard every day so we
set it up to email us when it seems like
there are issues with the alerts and so
you can see that a bunch of rules that
you know used to fire 40 or 50 times a
day suddenly stopped firing entirely and
we think she figured out that that was
an issue with the data Mart like it
somehow the rules actually we're firing
but the logic so the data wasn't sort of
flowing into the data market that was an
interesting sort of not French we found
a couple other sort of interesting ones
we've also been doing a lot lately with
something they were calling all you need
to just show you this graph upstream
anomaly detection so I told you guys
about the Meo turn psh graph it's the
same graph you can see up here but what
we realized was you know we knew the
logical elements of the rule right we
knew that independent on amiodarone and
psh and so we thought why do we look
sort of backwards and see are there any
anomalies and the rate of which meo door
is being
TSH results are being you know filed on
patients and it turns out that you can
actually see the change much more
clearly in this data this is bit rate of
adding a miata under patient's
medication let subscribe the amiodarone
and that light blue dots are the old
code for tea and then the black dr. code
709 9 now what's interesting about this
is I thought that the blue dots would
stop entirely but they actually persist
and the reason is that we use preference
lists for ordering medications and so if
you had saved amiodarone here like
favorites with ID number 40 we would
still let you prescribe drug for tea you
could no longer search for it so that's
why you still see some blue dots sort of
going forward even after the sort of
predominant switch but the boys on
change point detector finds this change
on this date which is cool because it's
actually a year before the actual
malfunction happens and the reason is
that you know this alert only fire
expressions that have been on the drug
for at least a year so this green bar
starts on the first day that we missed
an alert but the upstream detector found
the issue a year before the first issue
so rather than finding it our boys on
Judgment detector found a year late and
the option detector finds a year early
so it seems like it's a superior way to
sort of do this analysis and so we now
have a sort of job running that looks
for new medications that had never been
prescribed before and then looks for
similar medications just sort of
lexically similar medications in the
knowledge base and then looks for rules
that use those medications it basically
says like you know this is like a new
you know our new Atia lip day is like
that there's obvious like new you know
what look you know sort of you know flow
then which is sort of you know this like
you know if we take its own propionate
inhaler and there's this new esther
fluticasone fluticasone furoate that you
know is i don't know if it's better it's
we were expensive there's been a lot of
they Breo ellipta in our new what he
lifted inhalers and we didn't can't we
have a rule that what's for patients
that are on
you know he'll corticosteroids and it
didn't look for the fluticasone furoate
and so basically we figured out okay
here's this new inhaler it seems similar
to an old inhaler that old inhaler is
used in a rule and then we're able to
sort of fix the rule to take that into
account because it's kind of like
defensive rule maintenance or defensive
grouper maintenance something like that
so this is a new thing that we've had
running for like a few weeks I don't
know if it's used for not yet try to
evaluate it more formally they think
it's going to be useful again it would
be even better at the time somebody
first profile that's our new Woody
ellipta if we they got an alert and said
boy this seems similar to this other
thing are you sure you don't want to
change the rule I think somewhere things
though could could work so for
laboratory results in other kinds of
data so that's something we just got
running like really recently and I don't
know if it's useful or heart yet so
Arthur day at least to say about it is
really just about community
dissemination so we're supposed to apply
the results to a couple of community
hospitals one of which you've already
visited Holy Spirit hospital and one of
which we haven't visited so Baptist
Health in Jacksonville Florida and Holy
Spirit sort of messed us up by getting
acquired by geisinger so they went from
being a community hospital to being like
an arm of academic medical center but I
think the goal really is just to sort of
say like do these tedious anomalies and
taxonomy and best practices that we
developed large you're looking at
academic medical centers would reply to
the community hospitals which we have
many fewer kinds of CVS and many fewer
resources for maintaining RCDs only want
to sort of package up in disseminated
the dashboard software to other people
so we actually are hosting dashboards
now for four or five organizations that
wanted to have a dashboard so it's some
epic organizations and all scripts
organization in the Cerner organization
actually two different allscripts
organizations one of which is running
all scripts enterprise and one which is
running all scripts sunrise which used
to be eclipsys so our our thinking is
that this methodology isn't specific to
epic although we develop the rules for
epic but that it applies reasonable to
other other HR so if you guys are
interested we'd certainly be a type of
share the code with you or talk to you
about sort of creating a dashboard which
we sort of so far just do because it's
fun when you learn something every time
we do it so I think we talked largely
about these lessons learned I mean I
think he'd of anything you can add about
knowledge management is good you need a
lot of testing that's important to test
in the production environment
a lot of places that had bugs said you
know their music Russians say I could we
tested that two weeks ago it was working
fine and he say where did you test it me
and say we tested it in our test system
that's a read all our testing it's wrong
to cuts in the production system and
then we'd say what can we test it just
one time in the production system
they're like okay and then it's sort of
it's working in tests and broken in
production a lot of things that are
working in testing broken in production
I shouldn't happen careful environment
migration environment consistency
checking it's surprising how many things
have to do with sort of differences in
synchronization from your environments
proactive monitoring like you dashboards
dependency check the upstream sort of
detection and then you know it does seem
like we're building c.d.s it's more
complicated we're composing different
systems we're using web services and
apps and stuff and the trick is you know
it's hard to keep your EHR up 99.999
percent of the time if it's them
dependent on 11 other systems each of
which are only up 99.99 percent of the
time you guys can do math as well as I
can write like somehow that's going to
increase your failure rate so if you
have a few systems composed of lots of
systems every individual system needs to
be more reliable than your total
reliability goal and and we're not not
there yet right now I mean it was really
interesting I even just sort of treat us
like the drug classification system had
a sort of like strict you know 925
support model right no one was on call
with that went down there was no one
that would fix it tell the next weekday
and that's okay except then it broke the
CPOE system which needs to be up all the
time so somehow you have to be
thoughtful about about how they seem
sort of fit together so that's a that's
everything I sort of know I just want to
thank a lot of people who have helped us
from my hospital university of
pittsburgh who's helped us do a lot of
our anomaly detection some of our
friends here at ohsu Steve who's talked
to us about this stuff Joan and Jane who
have provided as her data collection
data analysis the insidious to be here
is not the mercy of Texas Ohio State who
was one of those actually visited and
helped us set some stuff up and then
other participating sites they're
provided data or have otherwise been
useful and that's everything I know so
thank you guys
[Applause]
yeah bill great great talk very
interesting kind of I don't know scary's
may be too strong of a word but come sir
thank you come what one of the one of
the things I don't notice and your
recommendations is anything around
benders yes I shouldn't some of these
responsibilities fall to vendors or does
it all fall to those who implement their
systems and what what what yeah you tell
vendors if you yeah we're invited to
epic maybe you have them what we can
tell them talk to the head of CVS no
moment an epic yesterday at lunch about
this exact topic so one thing a vendor
might say that the cousin said this but
some lenders have said this to us is
that you know so few of your cases
involved bugs in the EMR right like they
were all what they call mists
configuration of the system and so if
you believe that conceptualization that
epics responsibility or my HR burners
responsibility is simply to deliver to
me a working EMR and then it's my job to
configure it than they're doing a good
job but I think I don't believe that
that's the limitation of their
responsibility and I can don't really
speak directly for applicants earner
those are the people who had most
advanced conversations with they agree
and so I think you know tools that
vendors could deliver would be better
reporting for CBS so it turns out that
it's really hard in ethic and cerner to
report on CD s several organizations we
went to and surveyed actually said
something like you know there used to be
this one lady who knew how to get the
report but then she retired and no one
knows how to even look and see what cdss
firing it's awfully hard to imagine
you're a reliable CDC we can't even run
this report so we need better reporting
and Epica thing understands that is
trying to build better reporting tools
they've actually added some of the basic
anomaly detection stuff that we talked
about to their cuban analysis reports
the second thing is better knowledge
management tools right so epic has a
tool when i add a medication they're
deleted medication once we see which
order sets are affected by that it
should also let me see which BPA's are
affected by that and which gr rule is
never stuff like that so i think they
get it and i think the third thing they
can deliver is advice and best practices
to their customers so i think they get
it i think it's a new idea for them to
be that involved in the content but
i would say i only received positive
feedback from epic concern or where the
two burners we talked to but i think
it's a lot their fault if we want it or
not fall but it's a lot they have the
Opera House I got using the word fault
they have an opportunity to help and I
think I don't know that that minute that
most organizations have you know a steve
kiss akhiyan or a knowledge management
team like I have at my hospital to do
this kind of work and so we need to
depend on our vendors yeah awesome to
who yeah yeah so so yes and so epic has
developed this thing that they call like
a build checker that finds some common
[Music]
misconception of the time that people
add medications they forget to think
about where the root matters a large
president I'm glad medications to a rule
they forget to think about whether
they're talking about the order for the
medicine or the administration of the
medicine and so I think that there
should be some tools in my HR that help
me think carefully about these rules and
when I add a drug don't add a root
restriction they say you know wid dis
apply to eyedrops with the supply to
shampoos in addition to pills or
injectable medications so I think that
they definitely have a responsibility to
report that to their customers I also
think it would be constructive somewhere
between constructive and potentially
obligatory to report these kinds of
malfunctions to your patient safety
organization or to something like the
equity partnership for patient safety to
the extent that ONC ever does create a
patient safety center around the hrs I
think this would be the kind of thing
that should you reported there not to
punish people but so that we could learn
from them right like we found 44 cases
but if we could find a thousand we could
certainly build a better text on and
then we have right now yeah
oh thanks so awesome talk thank you I'm
curious I mean the anomaly detection is
obviously a very good approach to trying
to suss more out of the data that you
have yes one question especially given
the light that you've shown that you
know the kind of missing or decreasing
data is going to be the most challenging
to find yeah are there ways of building
in like a paired rule for instance or in
actually querying for the population
that you're not seeing as a check
absolutely yes so one thing that we
recommend to people in these anomaly
detectors are really good for finding
rules that we're working correctly and
then broke for some reason but a lot of
rules never work correctly is that it
might make sense basically to do a query
in your data warehouse to find the
patient you think the rules should fire
on and then independently like a
different person builds the rule and
then over time you know we often turn
our rules on you know in silent mode for
a month or something basically if we
said that these eight hundred patients
should get this alert the next time they
come in and 75 of them come in we get
then compare whether the rule fired on
75 of them to the data from our data
warehouse and see whether they're
they're different I think that's a
powerful approach the trick is that
people you know NASA used to have this
idea that like every program the Space
Shuttle was written by two people and
they would run both copies and that
would be good but my people make the
same mistakes over and over again so
there's this kind of like you know even
with parod work like if people make the
same mistake sometimes you yourself in
trouble but I think it's way better than
we have now we've done that only for a
few of our rules mostly ones that were
building for research purposes but I
think it's a really powerful method I
think it's a great idea yes sir
it did actually ask so there are a
couple of icd-9 to icd-10 examples one
of them was actually just out of a
classic coding example the other one was
really an interesting one which is it's
like almost too complicated to explain
but I'll track so we were looking for
patients that had certain icd-9 or
icd-10 codes and their diagnosis history
and so we created a grouper that had
some icd-9 codes and some icd-10 codes
and turned out that epic was trying to
do us a favor so if a patient had icd-10
code icd-9 code on their diagnosis list
it rather than checking that against our
icd-9 grouper it would translate that to
an icd-10 code and then check it against
our icd-10 grouper for us I was like
trying to basically preemptively fix the
bug that I think you're talking about
but the trick is that the mapping that
granularity 99 cd10 is not perfect and
so it was causing it to not fire
sometimes when it should and fire signs
when it shouldn't and so we eventually
we it wasn't really well that with my
opinion that will document it that it
was doing this translation we found a
way to suppress that translation that
fixed the problem so this was absolutely
a risky a risky time Aaron you any
question there's a bit of a comment more
to the question but maybe maybe I can
phrase it as a question I mean would you
agree I mean you were searching for for
a way to kind of give some more
responsibility to the vendors and I
think that so would you agree that I
mean these systems have gotten really
complicated in their incredible levels
of dependencies and they also introduce
new things like the story you're just
told which are features intending to
help you but they're kind of opaque and
really not even known to the users so
would you kind of agree that only only
the vendors can make some of this stuff
more transparent in their systems only
the vendors can provide the tools to
uncover the dependencies between the
different aspects out there so in that
way they may not have caused the problem
yet they're really the only people that
can provide the facilities to
effectively address the problem we can
do the research but they have to they
have to provide better ways of providing
robust
development for these systems a lot of
the systems have I mean they're really
large software systems right but they
have relatively poor software
engineering behind them like the
inability to understand the dependencies
between things so maybe yeah I think
that's that's a great point and I think
it's it's turkey even because when you
call epic it's often the first and
second person you talked to didn't know
about that weird little napper and it
was the third person that something new
I mean I I don't know if you're right or
not like I mean I'm sort of a date like
free market guy and like I think you
know let a thousand flowers bloom but I
was happened to work at a place as like
a lot of knowledge management resources
the train and stuff one sort of
provocative idea that I layout is like
what if it's so complicated that this
model world